So, so far the two operations that we've looked at have been query operations.
That is, they've been asking about the values of attributes. However,
in interesting information systems, in addition to querying,
you need to have operations that actually change the state of things.
And, so this is going to be ultimately implemented with the database and
you need the ability to add records, to change records, and that sort of thing.
We call particular operations that don't make any changes like this pure,
as in pure functions. Because they're similar to mathematical functions,
which always compute the same result. Functions which are impure,
are said to have side effects. And side effects might be changing the values on
the database. They might be doing IO operations, input output operations.
Or flashing something on the screen that the user sees. what, whatever it is.
So, those are side effects. And, so, now, as the next, next step in our,
modeling of these requirements, let's try to specify a more complex situation.
One where an operation actually results in a change of state. In this case, we
choose to model the actual process of checking out a Loanableitem as indicated
in requirement five. A patron can check out books or audio visual materials